mais est-ce qu'on peut l'arrêter pour
vous on ne pourra l'arrêter effet c'est
sûr que si sa trace il s'attache à la
lituanie à l'estonie ou à la roumanie là
les choses vont changer de nouveau
changé de niveau parce qu'évidemment le
temps ne va pas rester
inerte dans cette histoire c'est à dire
qu'en cas d'incident ou d'escaladé on
rentre au defacto automatiquement dans
une troisième guerre mondiale
c'est un risque il faut mieux le savoir
et il faut pas se il faut pas jouer la
politique de l'autruche en disant que
rien ne peut arriver on a passé son
temps à dire ça il ya encore huit jours
il ya quinze jours tout mon dieu non non
mais et même nous mêmes ici on ne
pensait pas que la folie
de du président poutine l'entraînerait
jusqu'à des actions telles que celles
que l'on s'arrête ça veut dire qu'il ya
un risque matériel
troisième guerre mondiale via le risque
d'une troisième guerre mondiale mais ici
il faut aussi prendre d'autres risques
qui sont nouveaux on risque par exemple
de subir y compris peut-être en france
des cyberattaques massives
moi vous savez quand je vais dans les
pays baltes j'entends un pays comme la
lituanie qui subit 57000 attaque cyber
pendant un week-end n'y a plus de
système hospitalier et le système le
week-end suivant il ya plus système
bancaire on peut avoir ça souvenez-vous
de ce qu'il a dit avant-hier ceux qui
s'opposent à ce que je suis en train de
faire en ukraine connaîtront des choses
d'une violence telle qu'ils n'ont jamais
connu auparavant donc est ce que ça veut
dire trois ans qu'il jusqu'où il peut
aller je vais solliciter la phrase
exacte un covenant est donné il doit ce
qui tombe d'interférer avec la russie
doivent savoir que la réponse de la
russie sera immédiate et conduire à des
conséquences que vous n'avez encore
jamais connu voilà il peut aller
jusqu'où il peut aller
jusqu'à des provocations militaires il
peut aller jusqu'à
la mise en oeuvre d' attaque cyber qui
peuvent être très handicapante très
dangereuse tout aussi dangereuse qu'une
intervention alors évidemment on
n'envisage pas aujourd'hui que la france
reçoivent des bombes mais il faut se
préparer et je sais que l'état major les
états major de l'otan celui l'état major
français bien évidemment se préparent
toutes nos forces sont actuellement en
alerte
se préparent à toute hypothèse puisque
face à quelqu'un c'est à dire y compris
des bombardements en france il s'y
prépare sûrement je n'ai pas le détail
de ce qu'ils font ici gelé je ne peux
pas le dire mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'effectivement on se
prépare dorénavant à toute éventualité
parce que lorsque vous avez affaire à
quelqu'un qui
fonctionne d'une avec dans une manière
tellement erratique et tellement folle
il faut se préparer à tout le président
de la république a été très clair et moi
je le soutiens dans cette phrase il dit
je vais protéger les français dans
toutes les circonstances nous avons les
moyens nous protéger nous avons des
forces armées nous avons des services de
renseignement nous avons des services de
sécurité visant à protéger nos
installations informatiques il faut
mettre tout ça en eux car vous ne savez
pas ce qui peut arriver alors il s'agit
pas de créer la panique générale mais il
faut il faut rester attentif à ce qu'il
est justement puisqu'on parle de cette
réponse j'en veux
[Musique]